- Welcome back to the "Spirited" movie
takeover of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
(crowd applauding)
- Yes.
- I'm your host for the day, Sunita Mani
and with me are my "Spirited" co-stars
Octavia Spencer, Ryan Reynolds,
and Will Ferrell.
(crowd cheering)
Our movie is an adaptation of the famous
Charles Dickens story "A Christmas Carol."
In the movie Will's character.
- Nice.
- Thank you.
You know British?
- Yeah.
Will's character has a hard
time remembering the name
of a rather famous character
from "A Christmas Carol."
I'm talking about Tiny Tim.
- [Will] Yep.
- Aw, love Tiny Tim.
- Yeah.
- Sweet, sweet guy.
Well, it's time to see how well
we can identify other famous characters
from literature with a game,
in Tiny Tim's honor,
this is super, small Steve.
(crowd laughing and cheering)
- [Voiceover] Super, small Steve.
(crowd applauding)
- Okay.
- Kelly sometimes has a
helpful host from above
for these games.
Let's see if he's here,
even though Kelly's not,
Lord,
(Will laughing)
can you help us with a game?
- Please, Lord.
(heavenly humming)
- [Lord] Well, I certainly can Sunita,
and by the way, may I say
you're doing a bang up job
on the show today.
(crowd cheering)
- Oh, that's nice.
- [Lord] There you go. That's right.
- Thank you, Lord.
- [Lord] And hello, hello to all
you beautiful folks down
there playing the game.
And also to you, Ryan.
Okay. Here's how this-
(crowd laughing)
- Dad?
- [Lord] Just go with it. Just go with it.
Here's how the game works.
I'm gonna read a clue of a
famous character from literature.
If you think you know who I'm describing
you're gonna hit that button
right in front of you
and give me the answer.
Now you can answer before I'm
done reading the question,
but if you're wrong,
(loud buzzer)
the other team will get a chance to steal.
That's right. You sweating now?
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- [Lord] The teams are
gonna be Ryan and Octavia.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- [Lord] Okay.
Versus Will and Sunita. Okay.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
Everybody ready?
- Yes, Lord.
- [Lord] Here we go. Here
is your first question.
This character was a woman who flew
in on an umbrella to babysit children-
(bell dinging)
- Mary Poppins.
- [Lord] It is Mary Poppins.
(bell dinging)
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- Did you try to?
- Umbrella!
- I did it after. (laughs)
I did and I took it back.
- [Lord] All right, here's
your next question, now.
It was this wise old character,
started out gray but
then turned white after
he was all like, "You shall not pass!"
(bell dinging)
- Gandolf.
- [Lord] It was Gandolf!
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- Very good.
- Very nice.
- [Lord] That's two
points, now. Come on now.
- Thank God you got that
I was gonna say Moses.
(Octavia laughing)
- [Lord] We would've accepted Moses.
We would've accepted Moses.
(bell dinging)
Go ahead, give them a point.
Go ahead. Sure. Why not?
I'm making stuff up.
- That makes no sense.
- What is this?
- [Lord] I'm God.
Anything goes. Don't worry about it.
All right, here's your next question.
This little bear was a silly old bear.
(bell dinging)
- Winnie the Pooh.
- [Lord] It is Winnie the Pooh.
- Wow.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd applauding)
- [Lord] And because I gave you that point
because I gave you that point,
we now have a tie everybody.
- Wait, what?
- [Lord] Making things
interesting. That's right.
Don't question me, don't question God.
Don't mouth off to me now.
- Okay, God,
- [Lord] There'll be trouble later.
- [Octavia] Sorry.
- [Lord] Here's your next question.
This character was
strung out on pixie dust
for most of his childhood,
which lasted quite a long time.
(bell dinging)
- Peter Pan.
(crowd cheering)
- [Lord] It is Peter Pan.
(crowd applauding)
Now we got ourselves game.
- I knew it was a child actor.
(actors laughing)
- [Lord] Well, we're
glad you knew that, Ryan.
We appreciate you sharing
that with the group
but that's not gonna get you a point.
You know what I'll give
you a point for that
because you're so cute-
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Lord] Because you're so adorable,
because you're so adorable.
(crowd cheering)
Will, don't worry about it.
- Okay.
- Well done with the Winnie the Pooh
- [Lord] Here's your next question.
Now this is gonna be a
really, really difficult one,
so pay attention. This
character walked past
a sea of twirly, swirly
gum drops before walking-
(bell dinging)
- Moses?
- Alf, elf, elf.
- Moses.
(crowd laughing)
- [Lord] Did you say Alf or Elf?
- I think he said Alf.
- [Lord] We'll accept
both. We'll accept both.
We'll accept both.
(crowd cheering)
- Buddy the Elf. Buddy
the Elf is his full name.
- [Lord] I believe-
- [Octavia] Buddy the Alf?
- Buddy the Alf is his full name.
- [Lord] Buddy the Alf, right.
I believe that may have
happened to Alf as well.
It was the Eighties.
- I loved Alf.
- [Lord] Right. This
is our final question.
- Okay.
- [Lord] That sound right there means,
(bells jingling)
this is our final question.
(crowd cheering)
- Okay.
- [Lord] Some would say it
didn't come soon enough.
Okay, here we go.
This one is worth 25 points.
- [Sunita] Okay, we gotta
get it, we gotta get it.
- [Lord] Just because
this game makes no sense.
Okay, here we go.
This character owned a chocolate-
(bell dinging)
- That would be Willy Wonka.
- [Lord] That would be
(bell dinging)
Willy Wonka and you just won.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- We let you have it.
- Finger guns.
- [Sunita] We let you have it.
- [Lord] Octavia and Ryan,
you guys are the winners
(crowd cheering)
but you know what? You know what?
Even though you didn't beat Kelly Clarkson
I'm gonna go ahead and hang
your photos on Kelly's Chicks
Wall of Champs, anyway.
Happy Holidays everybody!
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- Oh, that's huge.
- [Lord] Happy holidays.
- That's huge.
- The wall of champs.
- We did it.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you, Lord. Thank you.
- [Lord] You're so welcome.
Thank you and by the way I loved
"Rest in Peace Department."
Go ahead.
(Octavia laughing)
- Thank you God. Sorry about that one
and a lot of the stuff
I did in my twenties
(crowd laughing)
- [Lord] I remember everything.
I'll be watching you. All right.